oh my foot i mean that's not a good
start
got your own foot stuck in the door
come on man and we're off
and stop
i'm comedian ryan sickler and this is my
stepson derek crawford while we were on
quarantine class might have been out but
school was still in session all right
let's go
very serious business you have lives
especially this one
and your literal hands and feet
it was like an old country road and it
had an awesome hill to jump jumping them
yeah dude we jumped the [ __ ] out of them
oh
no hold on look at it
look at aloha
just heavy on the brakes i mean jesus
christ stay in your lane you're hurting
jerky with turns this is learner permit
i swear my brother on the driving test
my dad said he hollywood at the stop
sign he
tire never came to a complete stop my
dad's like he just failed he just i was
like yes i get to drive him and the damn
guy passed and my dad was like yeah he
didn't even stop at the stops just
trying to tell him like even your dad
was saying yeah like he didn't stop and
they had this little course on the
property out back and you had to take
the course there i lost points on two
things i lost points on not signaling as
i was pulling out of my parallel parking
space which i tell you all the time
and also i took it in a stick shift
shout out to anybody to pass their
drivers testing a stick [ __ ] but i
peeled a little bit of wheels on some
ice coming out of the parallel spots
they ding me on but i didn't fail but
those are the two things i lost points
on my brother ran a stop sign
[Music]
the first time i went on the freeway the
only thing that i thought that frio was
scary about was merging on watch where
you're going
was merging on to the look yes
was merging
in and and changing lanes as well i
thought changing lanes was like the most
scariest thing yeah changing lanes is
going that fast and looking at you know
your mirrors all the time
in here yeah
i'll tell you something my dad told me
and it rings true never trust a blinker
just because that person has that
blinker on
you'll see people driving out on the
freeway with a left blinker on for 18 18
miles yeah so when you go back out to
your dads are you gonna start working
again yeah i would like to work you were
little caesars before yeah i was a
little caesars before i don't know i
remember when little caesars came out
little caesars came out we all loved it
bay bay pan pan all right so let's go up
here and do some god help me freeway
driving so take the 405 north okay and
we'll get off wilshire west it's easy to
drive out here on the freeway because
you only go 10 miles an hour that's not
hard
no it's good that you work it's good to
have a part-time job i'm proud of you
for that yeah that's not easy basketball
volleyball part-time job well now you
got to get your grades up yeah i feel
like right now like as much as i hate
like you know my mom on my tail about my
work it's really helping me yeah that's
what you need yeah it's called a swift
kick in the ass
this is not good for my anxiety right
you're herky-jerky with turns
so what do you want to do for work what
do you really want to do like like when
i'm older i mean you're 16. i'll tell
you right now in college i change majors
so my time i don't really know what you
want to do but if you know it's good if
you know what i know i want to be like a
like you know like a sports agent or a
sports manager for someone to me that
just seems fun being around all these
sports people that
i didn't really you know get to be that
guy but i'm still around everybody to me
that would be so cool
and i just like doing business the way i
want to do it and not be told what to do
so you want to be an agent that's
a gun for hire you don't want to work
for a company or an agency yeah
and you can then you can make your own
rules
within the rules
i mean that's what all these comedians
are but you can make your own rules the
things i've done in life that i've had
to listen to everybody else have not
been as successful because some people
give notes just to give notes some
people give an opinion because they're
paid to give an opinion
but
everything else i've ever worked on
where i just trust my gut and do what i
want to do is way more successful than
all the other [ __ ] of listening to
people
chris rock said it you you work so hard
you get to this level and then when you
bring these projects to people like let
me [ __ ] it up now you're like just shut
up your all your job is is to shut up
i'm in this room with you right now
because of the work i've done trust the
work i'm done that's why i'm here anyway
all right you're doing good
hey jeff
your father
[Music]
[Music]
you